bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à l'occasion de la journée
internationale de la femme
la délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat organise aujourd'hui un colloque
consacré au mariage forcé ce matin une
première table ronde est consacrée à
cerner la réalité de cette pratique en
france une réalité difficile à chiffrer
pourtant elle serait de nombreuses
jeunes femmes concernées par cette
pratique tout de suite donc direction à
la salle clémenceau bonne matinée à tous
sur public sénat mesdames messieurs les
présidents mes chers collègues sénatrice
christiane kammermann gisèle printz
muguette dini anne marie payet des
collègues nous rejoindront dans la
journée mesdames messieurs chers amis je
suis très heureuse de vous accueillir en
cette journée de la femme au palais du
luxembourg
100e anniversaire de la lutte de clara
zetkin signalons le au nom de la
délégation sénatoriale aux droits des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les femmes que j'ai
l'honneur de présider notre délégation
parlementaire comporte comme sa jumelle
de l'assemblée nationale trente six
parlementaires 29 sénatrice et sept
sénateurs issus des différents groupes
politiques du sénat
notre mission est double contribuer à
l'information du parlement sur tout ce
qui a trait aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité entre les sexes et en second
lieu veiller à ce que ceux ci soient
prises en compte par notre assemblée
lors de la discussion des projets ou de
propositions de lois qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir un impact sur la
condition de la femme et l'égalité
nous prenons très à coeur son rôle de
vigie et je crois qu'avec le temps nos
collègues sont de plus en plus attentifs
à nos recommandations
dans le prolongement notre mission
d'information j'ai souhaité que nous
organisions chaque année à l'occasion de
la journée internationale de la femme
une rencontre qui nous permettent de
débattre avec d'autres responsables
politiques ou administratifs
avec des représentants de ce que l'on
appelle la société civile d'une question
qui intéresse la situation des femmes
aujourd'hui je crois beaucoup à
l'importance de ces échanges pour nous
permettre à nous comme à vous de prendre
la mesure de la réalité
c'est ainsi qu'en mars 2009 nous avions
invité une cinquantaine de femmes
remarquables qui venait d'accéder aux
responsabilités de maire de leur commune
à l'occasion des élections municipales
de 2008
elle nous avait fait part de leur retour
d'expérience et la façon dont elle
voyait l'exercice de leur mandat
mes collègues sénatrices et sénateurs et
moi-même gardant un excellent souvenir
de ces échanges
ils nous ont confirmé que les femmes
avaient davantage d'obstacles à
surmonter pour accéder à ses
responsabilités qu'elles avaient moins
que leurs collègues ou rivaux masculins
le droit à l'erreur mais que grâce à
leur courage à leur détermination elle
pouvait néanmoins s'affirmer gagner la
confiance de leurs concitoyens et
contribuer de façon très positive au
renouvellement de la vie politique
locale
ces témoignages nous sont précieux car
il nous montre la voie du combat que
nous devons mener pour la dignité des
femmes et pour l'égalité véritable les
discriminations et les injustices existe
et nous ne devons pas nous lasser de les
dénoncer sans pour autant nous laisser
enfermer dans un rôle d'éternelle
victime qui nous met maintiendrez
insidieusement dans une posture
d'assistance et donc de suggestions et
il ne faudrait pas retrouvé les notions
d' incapables majeurs marque du code
civil de napoléon qui nous ont coûté si
cher et dont il a fallu tant de temps
pour sortir ce message de courage et
d'espoir je souhaite que nous le
conservions quelque part dans notre
esprit en abordant les crimes dits
d'honneur et les mariages forcés dans la
terrible réalité nous renverra aux
aspects les plus sombres de la condition
de la femme aujourd'hui mariage forcé
crimes dits d'honneur de formes extrêmes
de violence envers les femmes dont se
serait tenté de dire qu'elles sont d'un
autre âge
si elle n'était aujourd'hui si répandue
dans certaines parties du monde est
présente en europe et sur notre
territoire
malgré l'horreur et la gêne qu'elle nous
inspire ou peut-être précisément à cause
de l'horreur et la gêne qu'elle nous
inspire
il semble qu'elle soit parmi les
derniers à sortir de cette pénombre dans
laquelle on a voulu maintenir pendant
des générations les violences envers les
femmes
il est toujours tentant d'occulter une
réalité qui dérange les violences envers
les femmes ont longtemps constitué un
sujet tabou
l'absence de données générales sur ce
phénomène permettait à bon compte d'en
minimiser l'importance que d'efforts
at-il fallu pour commencer à lever le
voile
la mobilisation des réseaux de femmes
bien sûr le relais des grandes
conférences internationales et notamment
celle de pékin dont nous fêtons le
casier ème anniversaire et qui a incité
les états mieux mesurer les violences
envers les femmes enfin cette enquête
nationale sur les violences faites aux
femmes en france réalisée en 2000 à la
demande
à l'époque de nicole péry qui était
secrétaire d'état aux droits des femmes
qui l'on doit d'avoir révélé l'ampleur
et la gravité du phénomène que je
n'avais fait qu'ébaucher en 1989 au
lancement de la première campagne de
sensibilisation de l'opinion publique
sur ce sujet la surprise et l'émotion
suscitée par les résultats de cette
enquête ont favorisé une prise de
conscience dans l'opinion et inciter les
pouvoirs publics à adopter une première
série de dispositifs pour sanctionner
ces violences plus particulièrement
celles commises au sein du couple
le sénat grâce à l'action de certains
membres de notre délégation a joué un
rôle déterminant dans l'élaboration de
ces dispositions d'origine parlementaire
puisque la première loi est venu ici au
sénat et avait été adopté je m'en
souviens à l'unanimité mais cette
enquête n'a couvert keane également les
différentes formes de violence envers
les femmes elle a révélé l'importance
des violences au sein du couple
elle a évalué les violences dans
l'espace public mais elle n'a pas
analysé ses formes de violence
coutumière que sont les mariages forcés
les crimes dits d'honneur aussi une
dispose dans ce domaine que de données
disparates et très lacunaires puisque la
lutte contre les violences envers les
femmes a été érigée en grande cause
nationale pour 2010
il faut en tirer parti pour faire
également sortir de l'ombre ces formes
de violence particulièrement
insupportable je souhaite que notre
réunion d'aujourd'hui contribuer et je
tiens à vous remercier tous et toutes
d'avoir répondu à notre appel
plus particulièrement nos intervenants
dont certains sont venus de très loin
pour nous apporter le fruit de leur
expérience et de leur réflexion
je pense en particulier à madame loubna
down in emery directrice adjointe d'une
importance l'association jordanienne de
lutte contre les crimes d'honneur qui
nous viennent d'amman en jordanie au
docteur robert merce arabiste turcologue
spécialiste des cultures du moyen-orient
qui nous vient des pays-bas à madame
jacqueline thibault présidente de la
fondation suisse surgir et enfin ma
collègue et amie anne marie lizin qui va
arriver sénatrice belge ancienne
ministre ancienne présidente du sénat
belge qui a beaucoup fait pour nous
sensibiliser à cette problématique des
crimes dits d'honneur et des mariages
forcés qui revenant tout juste de new
york pourra nous rendre compte des
progrès que l'on peut attendre en ce
domaine de la conférence de pékin +15
nadine morano secrétaire d'état chargée
de la famille la solidarité devait
initialement assuré la clôture de notre
colloque mais elle m'a fait savoir qu'il
lui était impossible d'être parmi nous
retenu par d'autres engagements je salue
en revanche donc la présence de mes
collègues sénatrice nous rejoindront
sans doute dans la journée alain gournac
et yannick bodin richard yong c'est en
fait représenter absent au dernier
moment nous sommes en effet en période
de suspension de nos travaux
parlementaires pour cause de campagne
régionale qui aura peut-être d'ailleurs
une petite incidence sur leur première
intervention mais madame elle nous le
dira sans doute tout à l'heure donc vous
êtes revenu spécialement au sénat pour
participer à la réunion d'aujourd'hui
soyez-en particulièrement remercié avant
d'ouvrir nos travaux je souhaiterais
dire un dernier mot sur l'esprit dans
lequel nous abordons je crois la lutte
contre ces violences que l'on qualifie
parfois de coutumière certes elles
touchent essentiellement des populations
migrantes et nous paraissent de ce fait
étrangère à nos
earth et importer d'autres régions du
monde où l'intérêt supérieur du clan de
la famille l'emportent sur celui de
l'individu je crois toutefois qu'il
serait réducteur de les interpréter sous
l'angle d'un conflit entre deux types de
cultures opposées et fermée sur
elle-même une conception européenne
privilégiant les intérêts de la personne
et des conceptions coutumière
privilégiant celle de la collectivité
certes aujourd'hui en france et dans le
reste de l'europe le consentement des
époux est une condition de la validité
du mariage et le choix d'un conjoint et
poux pacsés ou concubins pour la france
relève du libre choix de chacun
ce qui ne garantit pas je le dis en
passant la pérennité des unions comme le
montre la progression du nombre des
divorces
mais nous devons nous souvenir qu'il
n'en a pas toujours été ainsi
le théâtre de molière est peuplé de
jeunes gens dont les amours sont
contrariés par la volonté d'un père qui
veut à toute force leur imposer un
conjoint conforme à sa propre volonté
sans remonter si loin rappelons nous
qu'il n'y a pas si longtemps les
mariages étaient bien souvent arrangé
par les parents et ce dans tous les
milieux sociaux le crime d'honneur qui
conduit une famille à immoler l'une de
ses filles pour rétablir une
honorabilité collective que celle ci
aurait compromise par son comportement
nous paraît barbare et nous voulons nous
en croire incapable mais souvenons nous
qu'il n'y a pas si longtemps encore pour
des raisons très voisines on enfermait
dans un couvent les filles perdues ou un
peu trop rebelle
peut-être vous souvenez-vous de ce beau
film irlandais se magdalena sisters les
soeurs magdalene celui ci retrace
l'histoire de trois de ses pensionnaires
forcé
magdalene enfermée pour avoir été violée
par son cousin rose pour avoir eu un
enfant hors mariage et bernadette pour
être trop coquette avec les hommes et
tout cela se passait en europe en 1960
pour différentes qu'elles soient nos
cultures ne sont sans doute pas si
étrangères les unes des autres et la
nôtre on a peut-être dans son effort
pour s'émanciper d'un patriarcat
séculaire que quelques générations d'
avance sur les autres
quelques générations regardons tous et
convenant que rapporter à l'histoire de
l'humanité cette durée ait des
is war et il y a toujours besoin de
délégation de la qualité de la nôtre
pour encore dire et redire nos
indignations nos colères nos espérances
notre déception celle par exemple de la
nomination conseil constitutionnel la
semaine dernière ou pas une femme ne
figure sur les nominations de cette
année d'autres l'ont dit nous le diront
il nous pouvons à l'infini multiplier
les exemples
je crois que donc nous avons encore
beaucoup à faire
je me réjouis donc anne marie lizin nous
en reparlera tout à l'heure qu'à
l'occasion de la réunion des nations
unies qui si actuellement à new york
pour tracer le bilan de pékin 15 les
états membres de la francophonie est
adopté une résolution qui tout en
réaffirmant leur attachement à la
diversité culturelle n'hésite pas à
proclamer qu aucune considération liés à
la coutume à la tradition ou à la
religion ne doit pouvoir être révoqué
pour exonérer un état de l'obligation
d'éliminer toute forme de discrimination
et de violence envers les femmes
parmi ces formes de violence
inacceptables la résolution désigne
nommément les mariages forcés et les
crimes d'honneur
je vous remercie pour votre attention je
vois avec satisfaction que nous avons
déjà installé les participants de la
première table ronde et je vais prendre
place à la tribune à côté de ma collègue
christiane kammermann vice présidente de
la délégation et donc nous allons
accueillir sur la première table ronde
christelle hamel sociologue de l'ined
qui va nous parler de la réalité sociale
du docteur emmanuel piette médecin
présidente du collectif féministe contre
le viol et qui nous parlera de la
réalité médicale et la réalité vécue
nous sera apportée par le témoignage de
fatou diouf qui auteur du livre le
scandale des mariages forcés et de
karima qui est auteur de insoumise et
dévoilée
voilà mes chers collègues mes amis nous
allons débuter ce colloque et je vais
donner
sans plus tarder la parole à christelle
hamel sociologue ali net
merci beaucoup bonjour merci à la
délégation du sénat de m'avoir invité
pour pour cette journée quelle est
l'ampleur du phénomène des mariages
forcés
cette question a suscité beaucoup de
débats ces derniers temps et beaucoup de
difficultés surtout pour pour y répondre
combien y at-il de victimes en france
deux mariages forcés et qui sont ces
personnes quelles sont leurs
caractéristiques sociologiques répondre
à ces questions est évidemment important
pour la mise en oeuvre d'une politique
publique des deux victimes et de
prévention de ces mariages forcés qui
soit adaptée d'une part et efficace
d'autre part en terme de moyens humains
et financiers qu'il faut dès qu'il faut
utiliser pour répondre aux demandes des
personnes victimes alors répondre à
cette question de la mesure du phénomène
du mariage forcé fait partie du travail
des chercheurs des statisticiens
démographes des sociologues qui pour
cela doivent utiliser des méthodes
spécifiques pour appréhender une
question comme celle du mariage forcé il
faut donc mettre en oeuvre des enquêtes
qui doivent car répondre à certaines
caractéristiques pour pouvoir
efficacement enregistré un phénomène
comme le mariage forcé effectivement
fort heureusement le mariage forcé n'est
pas quelque chose qui est vécu par la
majorité de la population qui réside sur
le territoire français et en conséquence
pour l'enregistrer dans une enquête
quantitative
il faut interroger un nombre très
important de personnes pour pouvoir
identifier
les individus qui sont confrontés à ce
type de situation ça veut donc dire
mettre en place des enquêtes dont
l'échantillon sera forcément supérieure
à dix mille personnes interrogées sans
quoi on est à peu près sûr de ne pas
pouvoir enregistrer le phénomène ça veut
dire donc des enquêtes qui sont très
coûteuse en termes humains et aussi en
termes financiers et puis pour pouvoir
enregistrer ce phénomène de mariage
forcé il faut bien sûr que les
questionnaires de cette enquête
s'intéresse au phénomène lui-même et
dispose de questions adressées aux
enquêtés qui permettent de cerner ces
situations ce qui en soi n'est pas
quelque chose de d'évident effectivement
il s'agisse pas de simplement demandé
aux personnes avez-vous été mariée sans
votre consentement réponses oui non pour
pouvoir véritablement enregistré une
situation comme le mariage forcé car si
on pose ce genre de questions on est à
peu près sûr que les gens ne répondent
pas parce que c'est une question trop
direct trop brutale et qu'il faut
procéder un petit peu autrement dans le
cadre d'un entretien qui dure une heure
qui est très rapide dans lequel on pose
quasiment 200 300 questions individus
sur toute leur histoire
or on sait bien que quand il s'agit de
révéler des situations de violence
eh bien il faut réussir à entrer en
confiance avec les personnes autrement
dit il va falloir mettre en place un
dispositif de questionnements un petit
peu particulier pour réussir à saisir le
phénomène et ne pas le sous-estimer
alors en france une seule enquête répond
à ces deux critères d'abord tenté de
cerner le phénomène et d'autre part être
réalisée auprès d'un échantillon de
personnes très importants qui permettent
donc d'avoir une mesure du phénomène au
niveau national cette enquête s'appelle
trajectoires et origines enquêtes sur la
diversité des populations en france
c'est une enquête qui a été réalisée par
l'ined et par l'insee qui en sont les co
producteurs
et les maîtres d'ouvragé c'est une
enquête réalisée sur les immigrés et
leurs enfants donc une enquête qui cible
en particulier la population migrante et
les différents courants migratoires
présentes sur le territoire français et
qui vise à explorer les conditions de
vie et l'expérience des discriminations
raciales dans l'ensemble des sphères
sociales de la vie quotidienne l'enquète
examine donc les trajectoires scolaires
les trajectoires professionnelles des
individus et elle enregistre aussi les
trajectoires matrimoniale des personnes
autrement dit il s'agit d'une enquête
qui est plus centré sur les questions
d'intégration et de discrimination que
sur les violences aux mêmes autant dire
que la question des violences est
complètement absente de la thématique de
danse des enquêtes
ce n'est parce que ce n'est uniquement
parce qu'il y avait un contexte
politique où il y avait une demande
sociale et politique d'information sur
ce sujet que j'ai pu imposer les
questions sur le mariage non consenti
mais l'anc est elle même est donc assez
insatisfaisante parce qu'on ne peut pas
enregistrer les autres formes de
violence qui pourrait être associée à
celle du mariage forcé donc on n'a rien
sur les violences sexuelles on n'a rien
sur les violences conjugales d'une
manière plus générale ce terrain
autrement dit on est là sur une enquête
qui d'un côté est intéressante parce que
elle vous donne des éléments au niveau
national mais qu'ils insatisfaisante
parce qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
comprendre les circonstances et le
contexte dans lequel ces mariages forcés
se produisent alors cet homme quête
hamon a nécessité quatre années de
préparation de la mobilisation du réseau
d'enquêteurs des de l'insee donc plus de
300 personnes
elle a eu un coût important comme je
disais tout à l'heure 2 millions 400
mille euros et la collecte a été achevée
en 2008
nous sommes donc dans une phase
présentement de l'analyse des résultats
et donc d'exploration des premiers
résultats de l'enquêté
malheureusement je ne peux pas vous vous
présentez aujourd'hui le nombre de
mariages forcés pour la simple raison
que en période électorale l'insee est
soumis à un devoir de réserve sur les
sujets sensibles et qu'en conséquence je
ne suis pas autorisé à vous donner des
chiffres
par contre je peux quand même vous
donner des éléments d'informations sûres
sur les victimes qui sont enregistrés
dans l'anc est donc pour les chiffres ça
sera dans quelques mois et après la
campagne électorale de toute façon comme
je l ai dit tout à l'heure l'enquète est
représentative de la population migrante
et issus de l'immigration en france donc
dix mille immigrés 10000 descendants
d'immigrés donc des personnes nées en
france dont l'un ou les deux parents
sont immigrés ont été interrogés ainsi
que 3000 personnes nées en france sans
ascendance migratoire donc né en france
de deux parents nés en france et donc
les questions sur le non consentement
ont été posées à l'ensemble des
personnes alors comment le mariage forcé
et ils appréhendé dans l' enquête quelle
définition a été retenue pour toutes les
unions des personnes en interroger donc
pour tous les mariages
il a été demandé aux individus deux
questions pertes successives permettant
d'enregistrer le mariage forcé la
première était qui a pris l'initiative
de votre mariage de votre mariage et
l'enquêté devait répondre vous même
votre conjoint vous et votre conjoint
ensemble vos parents vos beaux-parents
et une autre personne de la famille ou
de la belle-famille donc cette première
question permettait d'identifier dans
quelle mesure les individus étaient
acteurs dans de leur vie matrimoniale de
leur vie affective ou dans quelle mesure
il était au contraire
soumis aux pressions familiales dans la
là la réalisation de leur mariage
venait ensuite une deuxième question
pour les personnes uniquement qui qui
déclarait que c'était leur conjoint
leurs parents ou leurs beaux-parents qui
était l'initiateur de leur mariage
et cette deuxième question était au
moment de votre mariage vous diriez que
vous vouliez vraiment vous mariez vous
vouliez vous marier et vous aimez vous
auriez préféré plus tard vous ne vouliez
pas vous marier et vous y avez été
obligé par votre famille donc trois
propositions de réponses qui quand elles
sont combinées avec la première fois les
réponse à la première question
permettent de cerner le degré de
consentement des personnes à leur
mariage
non ce sont des questions qui enregistre
en revanche pas vraiment qui a choisi le
conjoint
on ne sait pas si le conjoint a vraiment
été choisi par les parents mais on sait
que la décision de se marier a été
initiée par les parents parce que c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que de
choisir un conjoint
par contre elle enregistre très bien la
question du consentement la dernière
proposition vous ne vouliez pas vous
mariez vous y avez été obligé par votre
famille la enregistre bien les
situations où les enquêtés identifie par
elle-même que vraiment elle n'était pas
consentante
c'est clair dans la tête des enquêtés la
deuxième proposition vous vouliez vous
marier mais vous auriez préféré plus
tard enregistre des situations que
j'appellerais qui correspondent à un
petit peu au halo des situations un peu
flou qui entoure les mariages forcés
qu'ils sont eux plus plus identifiée
c'est à dire les situations par exemple
il y à une grossesse imprévue
et puis les parents exercent des
pressions pour que les familles pour que
les enfants régularise en quelque sorte
la situation ce qui peut être des
situations où les individus ne voulait
pas se marier aurait préféré peut-être
avorté
et donc des situations qui correspond à
un petit peu moins l'imaginaire qu'on
peut avoir sur le mariage forcé ce sont
aussi parfois des mariages ça correspond
cette deuxième situation des mariages
arrangés qui au moment du mariage était
consentie et puis il s'avère que le mari
est un une personne qui exerce des
violences et les victimes relisent leur
histoire l'histoire de leur mariage en
se disant bon finalement ce ce conjoint
ce que je l'ait vraiment choisi est-ce
que j'aurais pu dire non
et parce que la relation de couple s'est
avéré violente parce que la relation de
couple est insatisfaisante pour ces
personnes elles relise le moment même de
leur mariage avec un autre regard et là
se distancie par rapport aux valeurs
familiales et déclarent que leur mariage
n'était pas consentie alors qu'est ce
qu'on apprend avec je suis à toi la fin
voilà
à partir de ces questions on apprend
d'abord que le phénomène
je peux conclure d'accord ne touche pas
les personnes les courants migratoires
de la même façon les courants
migratoires les plus importants sont le
maghreb la turquie l'afrique
subsaharienne la vie du sud est et le
portugal qui sont les courants dans
laquelle ce phénomène est le plus
fréquemment déclaré on enregistre
également une diminution du phénomène en
fonction des années on voit que les
personnes qui ont été mariés dans les
années 60 ou 70 sont plus nombreuses à
déclarer un mariage non consenti que les
personnes qui sont qui ont été mariés
dans les années 90 enfin on voit aussi
que le phénomène est en diminution
si l'on regarde la population migrante
d'autre part la population des
descendants d'immigrés d'autre part
c'est à dire qu'elle touche moins les
descendants d'immigrés que les immigrés
eux-mêmes
alors pourquoi en parle-t-on plus et
bien parce que le profil des victimes
en revanche est différent à savoir que
les descendants d'immigrés et les
immigrés qui aujourd'hui sont confrontés
à six situations sont des personnes qui
ont un profil sociologique différents
elles sont plus qualifiés elle dit elles
connaissent mieux la société française
soit parce qu'elles y ont grandi soit
parce que elles sont plus migrantes mais
plus qualifiés également et donc leur
possibilité de chercher à faire obstacle
à ces mariages non consentis
ou en tout cas eux de les dénoncer
l'arrêt leur est plus grande et dans le
même temps la possibilité d'en parler
également et plus grande c'est à dire
que la tolérance à l'égard de ces
situations est moindre que qu'autrefois
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
dans cette situation paradoxale il y a
moins de mariages forcés mais en
revanche les associations sont
confrontés à des demandes plus
nombreuses merci beaucoup merci ont donc
on christelle hamel des informations
qu'elle a pu nous porter même si la
période vous l'avez compris pour
certains ça paraît mystérieux ces
périodes de réserve
mais c'est pendant les élections
répondent pas les influencer en principe
je doute que d'ici nous arrivions à
faire c'est grand chose quand les sus
des élections régionales
mais comme ce débat sera retransmis sur
public sénat nous avions le devoir de le
faire ici
voilà je vous reprécise quelques règles
du jeu pour notre bonne compréhension
ces manuels piette qui va maintenant
nous parler de la réalité médicale à
spec cheese world index qui est sans
doute eu de belles facettes five in dr
denis seine saint denis est énorme chez
weeden oui sa croissance qu'est ce que
c'est elle c'est exactement ça ça n'a
posé ça n'a commencé à poser le problème
que caen et en seine saint denis ça a
été manifeste on cette alerte et très
tôt moi j'étais responsable du comité
départemental de prévention des
agressions sexuelles et de la
maltraitance à l'encontre des enfants
et bien tout d'un coup et ça en 96
une assistante sociale a dit à
téléphoner en disant c'est parce que
j'ai joué avec un mashala très près 1
il marche mais faut être très près c'est
mieux bon ça va
et donc une assistante sociale téléphone
d'une assistante sociale scolaire c'est
elle qui sont alertés le plus tôt en
cliquant 710 en disant eh ben il ya une
petite qui va pas bien 15 ans et demi
elle elle allait très bien mais
maintenant elle va plus et elle vient de
raconter qu'elle a été mariée de force
que tous les week-ends le mari rande
qu'on a libéré la chambre des garçons
qu' il ya des rapports sexuels forcés
pendant tout le week-end qui a lu le
point appelé au secours et que personne
ne vient et elle dit que chez elle c'est
comme ça est ce que nous on dit ça aussi
et là vraiment il y en a eu quatre ou
cinq comme ça et on a été absolument
étonné parce que pour nous c'était des
viols pour nous était interdit et on
s'est dit là il va falloir faire
d'énormes actions de formation pour que
les choses changent et que les
professionnels et des réponse logique à
cette question là une petite fille qui
est violée à la maison c'est interdit
aussi même si c'est sous couvert de
mariages forcés on a une énorme l'action
de formation des normes d'actions de
sensibilisation puisque très rapidement
la plupart des professionnels de seine
saint denis ont été formés sur ces
questions là
au point que l'observatoire des
violences faites aux femmes
départementale a fait une enquête pour
voir un peu comment c'était les
violences faites aux jeunes filles en
général et 200 en particulier on a sorti
une étude spécifique faite avec l'ined
sur un bon mariage forcé donc voilà
l'enquète des comportements sexistes sa
interrogeait c'est sans enquêter 466
valable de 18 à 21 ans représentatif de
la population de seine saint denis juste
pour vous dire rapidement ces jeunes
filles là en seine saint denis
elles étaient les deux tiers habiter
chez leurs deux parents donc quelque
chose de qu'il faut quand même savoir
ils étaient les deux tiers à être bac ou
bac + 4 elles vont aussi pas si mal que
ça nos jeunes filles je dis ça parce que
quand même pas c'était donc une durée
moyenne d'entretien à 800 heures de
dialogues et comment est-ce qu'on a là
dedans repérer les mariages forcés
c'est ce que kessel disait pouvez vous
sortir quand vous voulez oui non vous
voyez que y'en a quand même
11 5% qui disent non deux cas types de
critères s'agit-il avec comment pour
choisir le camarade voilà ne pas être
violent avoir la même religion que vous
36% appartenir à votre communauté 12%
j'adore être sérieux ne pas boire ne pas
fumer
comment l'enquète repère les mariages
forcés votre famille vous at elle
proposé à fiancer
quarante deux jeunes fils se sont vu
proposer un chien c'est beaucoup quand
on sait que trois l'ont accepté et 4 se
le sont vus imposer
comment votre famille at elle imposée se
fiancer par la persuasion rien du tout
en vous faisant du chantage affectif par
la menace par la force dans
l'échantillon 1,7 pour cent des enquêtés
sont mariés au moment de l' enquête
elles sont donc parmi 42 jeunes filles
identifié comme exposées aux risques on
sait que trois sont mariés les autres ne
le sont pas alors plus l'âge des
enquêtés est élevé plus la proportion
d'être confronté au malaise français
augmente
douze sont nés à l'étranger 30 sont nés
en france de parents nés à l'étranger
la base sur ces 15 166 jeune fils et 742
qui viennent de pays où le risque de
demain d'être mariées de force donc ce
qu'on voit c'est que la migration
ça diminue très de façon très importante
le risque d'être mariées de force quand
même 42 sur 750 voyez que c'est quand
même assez peu parmi les jeunes filles
originaires d'un mariage à risque
quarante-et-une 42 suivant les diapos
sont exposés au risque 5 % d'entre elles
c'est quand même beaucoup parce que si
on fait ça à l'échelle d'une population
ça finit par faire beaucoup de monde en
seine-saint-denis ya quand même beaucoup
de jeunes filles qui risque sa les
enquêtes sortis du système scolaire sont
confrontés plus à un mariage forcé et
moin té étudiante mieux c'est alors
voilà donc ce que vaut ce qu'on voulait
vous montrer c'est que le contrôle de
l'apparence physique l'interdiction de
sortir nuytten 8ème jour atteint ils
sont de voir ce qu'elles veulent c'est
vachement plus chez les jeunes filles
on risque de mariage forcé est vraiment
exposés les autres se rapproche plus de
la population quitte
alors est ce que on a eu des relations
sexuelles avant le mariage et on voit
que là encore dans les traditionnels et
les exposer il ya très peu de rapports
sexuels hors mariage et 73% a souhaité
rester vierge jusqu'au mariage juste sur
la virginité parce que on dit c'est
comme ça moi qui fais des certificats de
virginité depuis 35 ans j'ai commencé à
les faire aux italiennes ça c'est fini
puis au portugais puis ça s'est fini
puis aux espagnols je crois que les
espagnols se lavant les portugais et
puis après ou tunisiennes marocaines qui
ont voit pratiquement plus en ce moment
je fais les gitanes et les pakistanaises
veut dire que les choses évoluent dans
le temps au fur et à mesure que la
migration évolué et ça ça me sens avec
ça moi important
les violences psychologiques dans le cas
de la famille vous voyez que là il ya
une vraie marque d'importance on les
jeunes filles exposées aux mariages
forcés sont exposés beaucoup plus que
les autres aux violences en général
psychologique et au harcèlement
psychologique aux particuliers et aux
violences physiques
vous voyez qu'elles sont plus vifs les
plus frappés plus tabasser plus enfermé
plus mise à la porte plus menacé avec
une arme et tentative de meurtre
c'est une vraie réalité et et ça il faut
pouvoir en tenir compte
même chose sur les lieux en se gravent
tabasser frappé 48% 18 menacé avec une
arme 18 face à après ça on peut dire
qu'elle voulait bien
bien la sexuelle vous voyez là aussi que
les taux de violence sexuelle est
beaucoup plus important chez les jeunes
filles exposées aux mariages forcés
tentative de viol 27% violent 10% état
de santé dana naturellement ça aide pas
aller bien 16 % considère leur état de
santé médiocres ou franchement mauvais
et les problèmes de santé chroniques 24%
se sentir mal dans sa peau 40% être
inquiet tout nerveux 5 4% désespérée
face à l'avenir 34% avoir des pensées
suicidaires 10%
vous voyez que quand même on peut dire
des choses ça abîme le mariage forcé
c'est ça abîme de façon durable parce
que quand on a été mariée de force on va
subir des viols après évidemment et moi
je me souviens d'une jeune fille qui
était venu me voir
bts bien dans sa peau trois langues va
vraiment une fille brillante et elle
devait être mariées de force
elle avait 19 ans et demi et elle disait
je vais le faire parce que les parents
jouent pas leur faire de la peine j ai
cherché à pilules pour finir mes études
après quand je serai diplômés tous que
j'aurai un métier je me tirerais et moi
j'avais dit ben on va vous dire qu'il
eut bien sûr mais peut-être que est ce
que vous avez pensé vous allez avoir des
relations sexuelles avec ce gars que
vous connaissez pas oui oui ça je
supporterai bon elle revient trois
semaines après à ses défaites chercher
la pilule autre chose etc
on discute un peu oui c'était parce
qu'elle pensait c'était plus dur
maintiendrait finira ses études etc
et puis huit jours après l appel en
disant je veux m'en aller
donc on la reçoit tout de suite et
j'essaye de comprendre ce qui est bien
ils l'avaient frappé il a violé c'était
pas grave ils l'avaient mais qu'il est
fort c'est frappé là elle supportait
plus et donc on l'aide à s'en aller
19 ans et demi vous savez il y a le la
prise en charge des jeunes majeurs dans
ce pays c'est discrétionnaire
discrétionnaire on ne sait pas quoi
c'est si on veut aussi machin etc
c'est plus de droits et ça vraiment il
faut que ça change parce que
quand elles s'en vont elles mais elles
ne sont pas deux droits protégeables en
seine saint denis dans notre protocole
on a décidé que les jeunes nageurs
devait être de droits protégeables mais
ça devrait vraiment dans la loi c'est
pas possible on peut pas dire simplement
conseil général peut pas décider celle
là elle est celle là je l'aide pas la
plupart ils disent bastion l'a aidé à
vent peut continuer un peu mais encore
faut-il que le contrat social soit
respectée on a ainsi pas d'être john
major aucun moyen de les aider et ça
c'est dramatique
alors celle ci on a pu l'aider on a fait
un truc dont l'amie de sa foyer de
jeunes travailleurs elle a pu continuer
ses études
et puis alors c'était je dis ça parce
que je veux pas croire que c'est facile
pour une jeune fille de quitter sa
famille de ne pas respecter les
consignes de plus elle disait je peux
pas travailler dans mon gîte et il n'y a
pas de bruit dans la chambre c'est vrai
elle était habituée à travailler dans la
cuisine avec à ce gamin il est là elle
n'attendait plus rien et puis mes petits
frères un sens il me manque
et puis et elle a redoublé et puis elle
à elle à un moment où elle à disjoncter
complètement elle est partie en
angleterre elle s'est drogué et c'est
seulement quatre ans après qu'elle a pu
récupérer quelque chose et et ressortir
et ce qui a fait qu'elle puisse s'en
sortir mais c'est que ses parents bien
voulu la revoir bien que décideurs ne
plus être marié poste il faut dire que
quelquefois pour ces jeunes filles c'est
très compliqué de sortir et que l'aide
ne suffit pas de leur dire viens on va
te protéger il va falloir une vraie
prise en charge cette jeune fille a subi
un vrai traumatisme
il va falloir prendre en charge au
traumatisme il va falloir l'emmener dans
un institut de victimes au il va falloir
l'aider à comprendre et il va falloir la
protéger vraiment car si elle n'est pas
protégée vraiment on ne peux pas l'aider
et ça ça demande et c'est pour ça que je
suis bien contente d'être là sa demande
vraiment qu'au niveau des jeunes majeurs
on est des mesures
autre que discrétionnaire quoi voilà
merci pour ce cette façon de présenter
cette question effectivement et cet
appel aux parlementaires de faire
attention à cette dimension de la
protection c'est en effet l'endroit bien
nous allons donc maintenant après vous
avoir remercié sur le respect l'une et
l'autre du temps nous allons je vais
donner la parole à fatou diouf et auteur
du livre le scandale des mariages forcés
avant de passer la parole à sa voisine
karim a donc fait tousser table
forcément si les paluds met donc bonjour
à vous tous avouent tout donc j'appelle
fatou diouf j'ai 28 ans et demi je suis
d'origine sénégalaise donc né en france
donc
auteur du livre le scandale des mariages
forcés donc ce livre a été écrit à la
suite d'un vécu donc mon vécu à l'âge de
18 ans des 199 je fréquentais un
camerounais non musulmans donc mon père
qu'il a découvert m'a fait croire qu'ils
avaient gagné un voyage pour deux
semaines au sénégal
arrivées sur place n'étaient pas un
voyage organisé mais une séquestration
de sept mois pour me marier de force à
un oncle de 36 ans à l'époque
bon il faut savoir que en tant qu
africaine sénégalaise l'oncle enfin
c'était le cousin ma mère mais pour nous
dès le départ on nous avait conditionné
en me disant c'est l oncle donc c'est
pour ça que je préfère le préciser
donc qui avait le double de mon âge qui
m'a connu depuis tout petit
à l'époque il était encore en france
donc la chance que j'ai eue c'est que
j'étais en afrique hui l'état en france
donc je n'ai pas été mais je n'ai pas
été violée je n'ai pas eu droit cette
mine noces entre guillemets donc c'est
ça je préfère préciser en disant
vraiment un violent parce que pour moi
c'est je le considérais vraiment comme
un viol j'ai été mariée religieusement
il faut savoir aussi qu'un mariage
religieux il n'y a pas besoin de la
présence des mariés à partir du moment
où là les parents des mariés sont
présents ça suffit amplement donc je
n'étais pas là le jour de mon de ce
mariage j'ai réussi à m'en sortir au
bout de sept mois grâce à une solidarité
d'une animatrice de radio que j'ai
rencontrés sur place du consulat de
france à dakar et d'une association qui
se prénomme femmes solidaires sur paris
qui m'a aidé dans les démarches
administratives
donc en fait juillet 2000 j'ai réussi à
m'enfuir en escaladant le mur de la
maison en prendre un taxi qui va amener
jusqu'à c'est cet homme qui avait des
relations avec le consulat de france qui
m'a mis au consulat et c'est vrai que la
première phrase qui m'avait marqué c'est
que en traversant le seuil du consulat
il m'a dit tu es sur les lois françaises
née parents ne peuvent plus rien contre
toi donc sachant aussi que j'étais une
sincérité française mais qui n'avait pas
de preuves parce qu'il n'avait pas de
papiers
ma seule preuve c'était ma carte
imaginaire et ma carte étudiante et
aussi le fait est que je n'ai pas
d'accent africains qui m'a sauvé et
c'est vrai que je rejoins un peu dont ce
que disait docteur piette ya rien de
pire
vraiment
là je quand je vous en parle j'en ai la
chair de poule 2 poule d'être trahis par
les personnes qui par les personnes
pardon qu'il ne mette au monde il ya
rien de pire parce que honnêtement j'ai
cru en mes parents je n'ai pas vérifié
les billets je suis parti avec confiance
arrivés sur place je suis rendu compte
que la confiance y en avait pas c'est
vrai que sur le coup j'ai pensé oh j'ai
pensé tout de suite à me suicider parce
que pour moi il n'y avait rien de pire
que ça après celle à qui est venue cette
idée donc d'écrire ce livre
au départ c'était partition témoignage
sur mon histoire et j'ai rencontré
charles anna rawson qui journalistes et
qui m'a proposé de faire une enquête
plus approfondie sur ces problématiques
qui est malheureusement toujours
d'actualité
en plus je suis l'aînée de quatre frères
et une petite soeur donc maintenant j'ai
ma petite soeur que j'essaie de protéger
au mieux je n'ai plus de contact avec ma
famille parce que au-delà de ce problème
de coutume j'ai quand même bon c'est
vrai qu'à aussi l'appel du sang qui est
plus fort que tout j'ai quand même
repris contact avec ma famille ça m'a
pris du temps mais malheureusement je me
suis rendu compte que quand ce n'est pas
la coutume c'est la religion
parce que l'actuel manche avec un anti
et non musulmans ça ne passe toujours
pas donc actuellement j'ai coupé contact
avec ma famille c'est très dur j'ai
quand même 28 ans et demi serait que de
ne plus dire maman ou papa ça manque de
ne plus avoir ce lien familial avec
d'entendre ses frères et soeurs ça fait
mal ça fait vraiment très très mal mais
honnêtement je préfère souffrir et avoir
eu le courage d'imposer mon choix de vie
que de soumettre à une coutume est de ne
jamais être heureuse d'être violer
constamment d'avoir des enfants mais
qu'un homme que je n'aime pas et que mes
enfants aussi on souffre par la suite et
par la suite j'ai été président d'une
association de femmes solidaires mais
dans 91 par l'intérieur cette
association je faisais des prévention
dans les collèges et lycées pour
prévenir de cette coutume qui existe
toujours
à la suite de ces préventions et déjà
une fille qui venait me voir pour me
parler de leurs problèmes
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi savoir
quand même si on n'en parle pas tant que
ça il ya aussi des hommes qui sont
mariées de force des garçons on n'en
parle pas mais je voulais quand même le
dire parce que dans ce livre il ya aussi
les témoignages de garçons qui sont les
culs ce mariage forcé qui ont témoigné
donc je tenais quand même à le souligner
je voulais aussi vous lire une lettre
d'une jeune fille qui crie naître à son
père qui est complète comme ça au mans
vous allez pouvoir
cette lettre bon vous disais pas un
petit secret c'est moi qui ai créé mon
père mais j'ai pas voulu le dire dans ce
livre donc je vais la lire très
rapidement
excusez moi je recherche juste la page
cher papa lorsque j'étais enfant tu n'as
jamais été sévère avec moi aussi plutôt
moment qu'ils avaient la main laisse et
qui me corrigeait souvent toi tu étais
distance strictes ton visage se ferme et
tu avais un caractère rude
tu ne parlais pas beaucoup moi je
n'oserais jamais allés vers toi tu
arrivé seul du bénin en 1978 d'abord
manoeuvre sur un chantier naval dans une
ville où parfois une léger à force de
courage fait devenus ouvriers qualifiés
puis chef d'equipe maman tu as rejoint
en 1981 grâce à toi je n'ai jamais
manqué de rien sauf de l'essentiel des
bisous des câlins de l'amour quoi tu
priais souvent sur ton tapis en
direction de la mecque
est ce que cette pratique qui l'a
éloigné de moi je te fuis deux suffisent
itil au point que tu pouvais te passer
de ta fille voulait tu que moi aussi je
sois une sainte
à partir de 11 2 11 ans je suis devenu
comme une seconde épouse pas plus haute
que trois pommes jeux 2d des mamans
nettoyer en briques en allant faire des
courses repas sans occupant de mes cinq
frères et soeurs
jamais un moment pour m'évader pour
rêver comme les copines que je
fréquentais à l'école un jour je m'en
souviens tu m'a fouetté avec un fil
électrique
tu m'as les surprises dans la rue a
parlé avec un français plus je
grandissais plus j'avais le sentiment
d'être une étrangère à tes yeux tu m'as
tu ne me regardez jamais en fait lorsque
tu m'a annoncé que tu allais me marier à
mon cousin reste au pays
j'ai compris que tu te moquer de mon
bonheur et que seul son honneur et son
rang de chef d'intéresser pour moi ça a
été un déchirement
je me suis révolté je me suis enfui
enfui pour échapper à mon sort que tu
avais décidé à ma place je sais que tu
en as été blessé que par ma faute au
village des profs font mal jugé que ton
l'honneur a été bafoué
mais je sais aussi que tout ce temps de
rupture et de drame ça fait réfléchir
nous nous sommes revus
tu m'as demandé pardon tu a souhaité
repartir à zéro
pourtant il a encore bien dur de se
parler et surtout de se comprendre
papa je ne te demande pas grand chose
juste de mai mais comme je suis et
d'accepter mon choix de vie même si
l'homme que je choisirais plus tard ne
saura peut-être ni de notre fine ni ni
notre religion tué mon père je ne
l'oublient pas je ne te renie pas mais
tu reste enfermé dans les coutumes
autre clan normal tu as grandi dedans je
peux le comprendre mais fait aussi
l'effort de saisir qu'à notre époque les
hommes doivent évoluer si tu ne
l'acceptent pas tu ris de me perdre
au fond de moi pourtant je sais que tu
peux changer je l' ai perçu le jour de
mes 25 ans sept ans après ma la suite
ce jour là tu m'a appelé pour me dire
que j'étais ton sang et que je te hais
que je te manquer je n'oublierai jamais
merci beaucoup fait pour cette de
témoignages émouvants et courageux et je
vais donner la parole à karima pour nous
parler de d'elle-même aussi qui a écrit
insoumise et dévoilée
merci bonjour à tous et à toutes
donc je me prénomme karima j'ai 34 ans
et je suis belgo marocaine beaucoup
moins histoire
elle a commencé dans les années 80 mes
parents ont décidé de déménager dans une
petite ville flamande pour s'installer
en à l'oni et mon père a fait
connaissance avec les voisins qu'ils
fréquentent et une mosquée et un petit à
petit ils ont incité mon père a
fréquenté cette mosquée et puis l'imam
dit à mon père donc un jour il dit tu
n'es pas bon musulman parce que pour
être un bon musulman il faut que tu
étais enfant vient à la mosquée pour
apprendre l'islam et donc du jour au
lendemain on s'est retrouvées à la
mosquée le premier jour on est allé sans
foulard parce que on n'était pas volé
les filles n'étaient pas volé à la
maison et l'imam a dit à mon père et
fille ne sont pas voilées t'es pas bon
musulman et on rentre à la maison mon
père prend 32 vouloir il nous laissera
tête sans nous expliquer sans rien nous
dire nous dit si vous l'enlevez je vous
tue et le foulard bon j'avais 8 ans le
foulard ne me dérangeait pas la mosquée
parce que toutes les filles portaient
mai à l'école c'était différent puisque
personne ne le portel et donc tout petit
j'ai commencé à voir une double vie je
l'enlever en cachette avoir d'aller à
l'école et je remettais avant de rentrer
à la maison
vers l'âge de 12 ans j'ai été promise
aux cousins donc
j'ai deux grandeurs et je suis la
dernière déficit non j'ai sept frères et
deux soeurs se sont mariés y rester - et
donc j'ai été promise à couzeix à l'âge
de 12 ans mais vers l'âge de 14 ans mon
père avait peur que je tombe amoureuse
d'un non musulman et il voulait trouver
le moyen de me garder à la maison donc
de ne pas fréquenter l'école tout en
bénéficiant des allocations familiales
alors on réfléchit sans un petit peu ils
ont trouvé le moyen de le faire donc ils
ont fait venir le médecin traitant qui
est une belle femme ma mère lui dit tout
simplement je suis malade je suis
fatigué j'ai besoin d'elle à la maison
elle doit s'occuper de ses petits frères
ses neveux et voit certificat médical et
le médecin son ensemble sculpté sans
réfléchir elle fait un faux certificat
de trois mois donc j'ai été séquestré
pour d'autres moins
tu me dis bon naître en moi ça va vite
passer je vais pouvoir retourner à
l'école et à ce moment là j'en parlerai
à l'assistante sociale
les trois passes
le médecin avait à la maison et ma mère
dit ben ça ne va toujours pas il me
reçoit un certificat et le médecin
refaire certificat jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire
je me dis voilà ils ont trouvé le moyen
ils vont procéder comme ça jusqu'à 1
jusqu'à mes 18 ans donc je suis coincé
soit je décide de me battre en sachant
qui a pris à payer ou alors je me laisse
faire
donc je quitte une prison pour pour une
autre celle chez le mari j'ai décidé de
me battre
donc je rédige un courrier adressé à
l'assistante sociale mais comme je ne
pouvais pas sortir il me fallait une
personne pour pouvoir l'envoyer donc je
les données à la moyenne qui venait
régulièrement la maison
donc la lettre a été envoyée à
l'assistante sociale l'assistante
sociale a dans un premier temps contacté
les singes et alors là il s'agissait le
service d'aidé à la jeunesse
comme j'étais mineure à l'époque c'est
le seul organisme qui pouvait intervenir
donc elle a expliqué la situation le il
s'agit a tout simplement répondu écoutez
c'est leur culture c'est leur communauté
ont préféré ne pas y toucher et elle n'a
pas voulu en rester là la contacter
l'agente qui retient bim.fr ils
pouvaient très bien ne pas intervenir
puisqu'il n'avait pas reçu de dossier
rien donc je pouvais dire non je ne
m'occupe pas de ça mais il est quand
même intervenu donc il est venu trouver
mon père rappelant l'obligation scolaire
et grâce à ce médecin j'ai pu regagner
l'école l'assistante sociale savais que
j'étais séquestré elle savait que voilà
que c'était des faux certificats que je
n'étais pas malade mais ne savez pas
tout et ne savais pas que j'étais
j'étais promise à un cousin savais pas
que j'étais battu donc tout ça ne savait
pas et ce jour là j'ai décidé de tout
lui raconter donc j'arrive à l'école
jean lève au foulard au cachette je
rentre dans son bureau et je mets à lui
raconter le calvaire que je vivais et au
moment où je lui raconte mon père
débarque n'a pas vu arriver et il me
voit comme ça sans foulard il est rentré
dans une colère
il m'a insulté il m'a menacé devant
l'assistance sociale il a voulu me
reprendre à ce moment là mais
l'assistante sociale s'est interposé
physiquement el hadi est hors de
question que vous la reprise est
maintenant venu la chercher à ses heures
si vous voulez donc mon père par m'a dit
je vais chercher à ses heures entre
temps l'assistante sociale mme dumais il
est énervé là rien faire et là je lui
montre les coûts je dis bah voila je
suis battu tous les jours et qu'est ce
qu'elle fait donc elle m'a même chez un
médecin pour faire constater des coûts
on a eu le certificat puis on est allés
chez le juge de la jeunesse est donc là
on est tombé sur la secrétaire qui nous
a dit faut passer par les s'agit
l'assistante sociale a expliqué qui ne
s'occupait pas des
et des personnes d'origine maghrébine
parce qu'apparemment ils ne connaissent
pas la culture les coutumes et donc on a
pu rencontrer la juge
donc il a vu le certifier les faits il
avait des coups il m'a entendu il a
entendu l'assistante sociale et là j'ai
été placé dans un centre
j'ai été placé je me sentais libre
quelques mois plus tard mes parents me
recontacte mon père me dit écoute ma
fille rentre à la maison tu feras ce que
tu veux tu te marier avec qui tu veux tu
pourras reprends tes études
j'y ai cru j'y ai cru je suis rentré
avec un suivi mon père qui était guide
pèlerine propose un voyage en arabie
saudite par terre ils partaient chaque
année donc mais je me dis l'arabie
saoudite pourquoi pas et je suis parti
avec avec mes parents le voyage s'est
super bien passé je restais deux mois
avec avec eux là bas ça s'est super bien
passé on est revenu après deux mois et
puis les mois passent il me propose un
voyage au maroc mais je me dis l'arabie
saoudite s'est bien passé le maroc ce
sera la même chose on est parti en
voiture trois jours de route
tout se passe bien on arrive à la douane
au maroc mon père me regarde et me dit
ici c'est le pays où la paire commanda
fille ils avaient mon passeport mais je
n'ai pris à la rigolade je n'ai pas pris
au sérieux
on est arrivé dans notre maison à main
et là il m'a attrapée dans la cage
d'escalier et s'est vengé sur tout le
temps il n'a rien pu faire et s'est
vengé et il m'a dit si tu feras ce que
moi je t'ai dit faire ce à dire tu te
marier avec ton cousin
ma mère s'est interposé et c'est la
première fois qu'elle s'interpose s est
jamais interposés pourquoi ce qu'elle
s'est interposé parce que mon père
voulait que je marie avec son but à lui
tandis que ma mère voulait que je me
marie avec son duel
et donc ça a été comme ça pendant
pendant deux mois mes parents se
disputaient et j'ai pu revenir quand
même après deux mois grâce à ma mère je
n'étais plus en obligations scolaires
puisque puisque j'avais 18 ans donc de
nouveau je me suis retrouvée séquestrée
mais je me dis j'ai échappé aux mariages
forcés les semaines passent mon père
soit recommandée du maroc tout contente
tout heureux une demande de
l'accompagner à la commune arrivée
devant la commune
il me sort le contenu de donc de
l'envelope et c'était l'acte de mariage
et par procuration verbal le père a
marié sa fille donc je me suis retrouvé
civilement marien et je me dis je vais
voir jusqu'où ça va ça va nous mener
mais j'étais décidé à accepter
donc je réfléchis je me dis comment ce
que je vais faire jusqu'au jour où mon
père avait envoyé le regroupement
familial etc
jusqu'au jour où mon cousin on voit le
numéro de visa dont quinze jours après
il était ici en belgique
enfin j'ai ici à côté et je me dis je
dois me battre il peut il ne doit pas
venir ici s'il vient ici je suis coincé
j'ai écrit un courrier adressé au
service des étrangers en expliquant la
situation en mettant le numéro deux
visages du manant sylviane six mariages
forcés sylvie s'il vient ici et qui
m'arrive quelque chose vous l'aurez sur
la conscience très vite son visa était
bloquée n'a jamais pu mettre ses pieds
ici et donc je me dis je dois partir en
restant chez mes parents j'étais j'étais
coincé mais je dois partir comme j'ai
toujours procédé par écrire je me dis je
vais écrire un courrier jeu j'ai créé un
courrier comme si ça bureau qui me
convoquer il fallait penser à tout parce
que ma mère ne pouvait pas sortir
d'aucuns pouvaient vraiment accompagner
mon père risque est donc content de ma
compagne est quand même alors j'ai
choisi à vendredi
donc le jour de la prière à 14 heures le
jour j je suis parti et ce à la fois de
mon père qui m'a sauvé j'étais livre
mais
j'étais quand même prisonnière de ma vie
parce que civilement j'étais mariée j'ai
entamé d'abord une procédure
d'annulation de mariage je me dis ça va
aller très vite
finalement la procureur m'a dit votre
père risque d'être condamné les
j'arrêtais la procédure parce que mon
père ça reste quand même mon père malgré
tout et j'ai entamé une procédure de
divorce jeudi un an deux ans maximum
j'obtiendrai le divorce quatorze ans
après je n'étais toujours pas divorcer
et mes frères m'ont bon frère me dit
viens passer cette année les 100 du mi6
les vacances ans au maroc
je n'étais plus retourner parce que
j'avais quand même peur d'être tués
l'avant mes frères ont insisté m'ont dit
on est là pour te protéger je me disais
je vais tenter je vais aller je suis
retourné au maroc et j'ai fait
connaissance d'un juge donc je lui
explique ma situation je dis bien voilà
ça fait 14 ans que je suis marié je n'ai
jamais vécu avec le type ce mariage
forcé il m'a dit écoute tu as qu'une
solution pour t'en sortir tu dois
procéder comme ton père a procédé c'est
à dire tu dois acheter le divorce j'ai
un bon on dit oui et je peux m'en
charger donc il me dit ah vous tue
retourner en belgique de joe flacco
quelques jours après tu m'envoies par
fax
l'acte de mariage et je me charge de
tout donc c'est ce que je fais je rentre
en belgique je lui faxe les jours
passent hymne téléphone et me dit voilà
j'ai tourner divorce est donc j'ai pu
divorcer mon histoire j'ai toujours
voulu décrire pour pouvoir me
reconstruire parce que on en garde des
séquelles
on peut pas oublier on peut apprendre je
veux dire on peut se reconstruire mais
on peut faire oublier
et moi ma thérapie c'était l'écriture
donc j'ai mis ma famille au courant j'ai
dit voilà je vais créer mon histoire
isaure hier parce que ça faisait des
années que je leur en parler ne m'ont
pas prise au sérieux
jusqu'au jour où il ya eu le l'extrait
sur le site de l'éditeur
et alors là ils ont fait comme si tomber
de haut
ils m'ont insulté ils m'ont menacé et
ensuite ils vont intenter un procès en
référé pour faire interdire le livre de
la vente si j'ai gagné j'ai gagné le
procès parce que bon hein on m'a demandé
des preuves de tout ce que je racontais
dans l'île c'était pas évident le
mariage forcé bon j'avais la preuve est
son acte de mariage
il faisait cris par procuration verbal
le père a marié sa fille l'assistante
sociale est venue témoigner le juge est
venu témoigner
mes anciens profs sont venus témoigner
les voisins etc et il me manquait une
preuve des faux certificats parce qu'ils
vont ce médecin avait comme le fait
défaut pendant 11 ans et donc je suis
allé là trouver je lui dit écoutez voilà
moi je passe en procès je dis vous
souvenez de ce que vous avez fait elle
m'a dit oui j'étais naïf à l'époque j'ai
maintenant si vous voulez vous racheter
entre guillemets vont attesté par écrit
que vous avez fait défaut pendant onze
ans l atc par écrit et alors j'ai gagné
procès en gagnant le procès j'ai
énormément de témoignages de femmes et
de filles qui ont vécu la même chose que
moi des garçons qui ont vécu la même
chose que moi et des personnes qui
vivent la même chose que moi j'ai eu des
demandes des demandes donc des appels
dead et et alors là qu'on a fondé une
association par rapport à toutes les
demandes et c'est alors la première
chose qu'on a fait avec l'association ça
je trouvais quand est important parce
que j'en ai marre d'entendre certains
médecins qui me disaient oui tu sais
karima des faux certificats ont fait
plus ça n'existe plus ça existait ya 10
15 ans et j'ai sélectionné une dizaine
de médecins au hasard sur internet et
j'ai téléphoné j'ai fait un accent donc
celle qui comprend pas bien le français
en disant ben voila je suis musulmane
j'ai ma fille de 8 ans une fois
certificat pour qu'elles soient
dispensés des cours de gym et de
natation par téléphone le premier
médecin me dit donnez moi votre adresse
je vous l'envoie par courrier donc ces
certificats d'un an et sur les dix
médecins y en a sept qui ont accepté de
le faire et j'ai eu trois refus est
parmi les trois refus il y avait un
médecin d'origine marocaine
il m'a dit quelques soient vos
convictions la natation et la gym ce
sont des courbes on est important pour
la santé moi je ne le ferais pas et donc
ça c'est la première chose qu'on a fait
avec l'association
je vais pas vous que je vous parlais de
tous les cas que nous avons traité
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui je peux vous
donner peut-être des chips si je vous
dis c'est et position puisqu'on
travaille toujours de quoi qu'on
intervient on fait toujours une
intervention d'accord tout fait une
intervention fait toujours une
déposition à la police sans la
déposition
on peut pas intervenir parce qu'on doit
se protéger on doit protéger la personne
et si je vous dis 16 interventions sur
14 jours c'est énorme et il n'y en
aurait qu'une seule
c'est une de trop et je vais vous parler
d'un cas justement parce que ces
personnes m'ont accompagné aujourd'hui
sont ici dans la salle comme fatou a
parlé tout à l'heure justement de
des garçons qui sont mariées l'a forcé à
garçon qui a été mariée de force il est
ici dans la salle
je vais vous expliquer un peu leur
histoire c'est la police qui nous
appelaient un bon jour il ya quatre mois
de ça en me disant il ya deux personnes
qui ont été mariées de force ils sont
d'origine pakistanaise
est-ce que vous pouvez intervenir je dis
oui bien sûr on est allé on a été les
chercher et on les a cachés pendant
pendant quatre mois dans la communauté
pakistanaise en défiance dès la
naissance et ces deux personnes visées
fiancée entre eux et à l'adolescence ils
sont tombés amoureux mais il ya eu une
embrouille entre les deux familles et
ils ont été tous les deux contre un
d'épouser quelqu'un d'autre donc on les
a mariés de force au pakistan mais ils
ne se sont jamais oubliés on continue à
cnn ils sont partis de première fois ils
ont pris la fuite
la famille les a retrouvés grâce à un
employé de la banque qui leur a dit bah
écoutez votre soeur affaires retrait à
tel endroit et les eaux retrouver des
ont séquestré la personne pouvait sortir
que si elle avait des convocations de la
police
et c'est comme ça que la police nous
appeler donc on est allé la chercher
et comment ce qu'on travaille en fait au
départ les gens nous appellent les
victimes nous appelle on allait chercher
les victimes on les mettait dans les
foyers pour femmes battues
mais ce ne sont pas des cas sociaux
c'est pas des cas sociaux et c'est les
foyers pour femmes battues ce ne seront
pas des endroits pour elle parce qu'elle
se retrouve avec des drogués des
alcooliques à ne pouvait pas se
reconstruire et très vite alors on a
construit un
on a monté un réseau de familles
d'accueil on est une trentaine sur la
belgique donc un peu partout et elles
peuvent se reconstruire plus facilement
dans une famille d'accueil viennent
entourer plutôt que d'être dans un dans
un foyer où elle se retrouve avec 10-15
personnes à qui on qui ont des problèmes
et alors donc ces deux personnes on les
a cachés on les a cachés pour d'autres
moins trois mois après les familles
seront montés jusqu'à nous et comment ce
qu'ils sont remontés jusqu'à nous l'un
la soeur de la vie a téléphoné à un
organisme de payement la csc en se
faisant passer pour elle en disant qu'à
écouter
quelle adresse est ce que vous avez dans
votre ordinateur parce que je ne reçois
pas le courrier et lv a donné l'adresse
où la fille était mais heureusement
qu'on avait quelqu'un de l'association
qui a repéré des nouvelles têtes
pakistanaise dans la ville où ils
étaient cachés
donc on a là on a appelé la police ils
ont fait un contrôle de la voiture
contrôle d'identité et c'était le guet
ses frères dont on les a évacués dans
une autre famille alors si on intervient
par exemple dans à bruxelles donc dans
la capitale on ne laisse jamais la
victime dans la même ville on l'envoie 1
100 s'accorde 200 km parce que voilà il
faut quand même les protéger alors ce
qu'on vient de faire en fait c'est tout
récent parce qu'on a eu énormément de
problèmes avec la police aussi donc défi
qu'ils allaient faire une déposition à
la police pour dénoncer un mariage forcé
pour dénoncer les violences intra
familiales etc
elles ont énormément difficulté sans
preuves on ne sait rien faire ça sert à
rien de faire une déposition et alors
c'est tout nouveau maintenant on a monté
avec la procureure du roi
la magie serin on nous a mis à
disposition deux commissaires et un
inspecteur et chacun est pris au sérieux
et toutes les personnes pour qui on
intervient automatiquement le bénéficie
d'une protection policière
et donc tous asséné dans notre ville
donc à verviers mais en commençant à se
tordre un peu partout donc ça c'est tout
nouveau sinon bah les familles d'accueil
on a une trentaine et il faut dire quand
même que on est tous des bénévoles de
l'association
ce sont tous des personnes qui ont vécu
ce que moi j'ai vécu ces deux personnes
moi j'ai 34 ans ce sont des personnes de
44 ans ce sont des personnes de 25 ans
donc c'est pas une génération c'est pas
deux générations c'est pas trois
générations et sur trois générations
rien qui a changé et rien qui a changé
et ce n'est pas normal
et donc voilà par rapport à 1 au travail
si vous avez des questions mais je
terminerai pas revenir de l'être parce
qu'en fait très important de faire la
différence entre l'islam et les
traditions le coran n'a jamais dit qu'il
faut marier sa fille de force
enfin moi personnellement cote quand
j'ai subi tout ça je me suis remise en
question par rapport à l'islam je me
dise c'est quoi cette religion qui
épouse le voile qui appose le mariage
forcé qui appose toussaint et j'ai voulu
rejeter l'islam mais après j'ai pris le
corps en gelée lui attire attentivement
et je n'ai trouvé nulle part une prince
qui dit que la femme devait se soumettre
ok la femme n'avait rien à dire que du
contraire j'ai trouvé une religion de
paix et d'amour et donc c'est très très
important de ne pas mettre de ne pas
mettre cette problématique sur l'islam
l'islam c'est une chose les traditions
c'est une autre donc je vais vous lire
deux lettres une qui j'adresse non
seulement à mes parents mais qui
j'adresse à tous les parents et ensuite
une lettre qui j'adresse aux politiciens
donc je ne sais pas si certains d'entre
vous ont entendu parler de sadia sadia
la jeune pakistanaise qui s'est fait
assassiner en 2007 par son frère tout
simplement parce qu'elle refuse un
mariage forcé ensuite il ya eu une aura
nora c'est une jeune une jeune fille de
19 ans l'année dernière s'est jetée par
la fenêtre elle a voulu fuir un mariage
forcé et elle est morte et dernièrement
il ya deux trois mois il ya eu l'oeil
leila un fichier qui a été calcinée par
un expert du coran pour la simple raison
qu'elles étaient homosexuelles doxa
diane morin les nains et toutes les
autres dont nous n'avons jamais entendu
parler qui sont mortes hausse et
laissent mourir de désespoir dans
l'anonymat elles sont elles sont
victimes de ces traditions qui ont fermé
parents et enfants qui déshumanise qui
écrase les individus et les familles au
nom de valeurs d'un autre âge au nom du
corps dira-t-on on ne les oubliera
jamais bien sûr nombreux sont ceux et
celles qui instrumentalisent la religion
musulmane comme d'autres instrumentalise
le christianisme le judaïsme ou d'autres
convictions encore pour assouvir leur
soif de pouvoir sur leurs enfants leurs
épouses leurs proches et ce sont
précisément ces attitude destructrice
qu'il faut condamner et combattre au nom
de nos valeurs universelles de valeurs
de justice d'amour et de solidarité
les musulmans se sentent insultés quand
ils entendent que certains d'eux
certains d'entre eux manipulent leur
religion pour opprimer leurs enfants et
leurs familles et donnant ainsi de
l'islam une image détestable
selon la religion islamique le mariage
est l'établissement d'un contrat
mutuelle entre époux fondée sur
l'égalité le respect l'amour et la
complémentarité
chaque époux à en apportant sa
contribution au bon fonctionnement du
couple
comment une telle relation pourrait-elle
naître de la contrainte de l'obligation
de se marier avec quelqu'un que l'on ne
connaît pas que l'on aime pas et parfois
même que l'on n'a jamais vus
toutes les écoles de droit musulman
stipulant qu'aucun mariage ne peut avoir
lieu sans consentement explicite des
personnes concernées rien ne justifie
aujourd'hui ses coutumes tribales que le
prophète avait déjà combattu en son
temps quand les femmes était une
marchandise et une monnaie d échange
entre familles et tribus cette tradition
now pourtant perdurer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est inacceptable
intolérable et il est temps que les
parents mettent un terme à ces pratiques
il en va de même pour la violence envers
ses enfants général le prophète fut un
exemple en la matière jamais jamais eu
l'aval à mettre ses enfants
il montera toujours une grande tendresse
envers eux mais également envers tous
les enfants une famille équilibrée et
fondé sur le respect de chacun parents
comme enfants et sur un amour véritable
qui fait grandir et kinés qui n'étouffe
pas nos prespa ne détruit pas on en est
très loin aujourd'hui le message que
j'adresse aux parents aujourd'hui
arrêter ses traditions archaïques pour
que nos enfants puissent envisager un
avenir plus serein dans lequel ils
seront enfin considérés comme des avis
des aides des individus responsables
avec leurs droits et leurs devoirs comme
tous les autres et non comme toujours
soumis à la pression de la famille du
groupe du quartier du village d'origine
aujourd'hui c'est notre combat commun à
tous quels que soient nos convictions et
nos valeurs de départ et je terminerai
par adresser
donc c'est un message que j'adresse à
tous les politiciens
rappelez vous où vous tombez bien je
m'adresse à tous ces hommes qui ont
signé les droits de l'homme un appel un
rappel est ce vraiment trop demander
mais où sont ces hommes trop de finir
leurs droits trop de gens se taisent je
ne veux pas me taire il faut que cesse
cet enfer c'est l'histoire d'une vie
l'histoire d'une fille c'est peut-être
ta vie peut être ta fier je ne renie pas
ma religion
je n'oublie pas mes racines mais je
dénonce haut et fort
l'instrumentalisation
ce n'est pas dans la religion ce ne sont
que des traditions ne vous voilez pas la
face la réalité est en face faut-il
attendre d'autres larmes à tordre
d'autres drames combien de fille
torturée ont vu leurs vies bafouées
je rends hommage à toutes ces filles qui
se sont renfermés
elles ont payé de leur vie le prix de la
liberté
je demande que l'on m'entende que les
lois soient appliquées
prenez vos responsabilités mettez vos
peurs de côté merci
merci beaucoup carrément merci a servi
les deux très sincèrement d'accepter de
nous dire ici en public et pour un
public nombreux qui vous entendra j'en
suis persuadé sur la chaîne public sénat
ce qui fait combattre votre vie donc
c'est très précieux nous avons bien
entendu la lettre aux politiques on va
dire aux politiques plutôt qu'aux
politiciens c'est très mal connoté pour
nous en france en tout cas donc nous
savons bien nous les femmes politiques
que nous devons convaincre nos collègues
masculins
deux de ces réalités et donc c'est aussi
le sens de cette organisation ce matin
salut alain gournac notre vice
présidente qui vient d'arriver il a
entendu la lettre voilà mais il est de
notre combat déjà depuis bien longtemps
voilà je peux peut-être prendre une ou
deux questions si vous avez des
questions précises ou sinon nous gardons
pour la fin de matinée après la deuxième
table ronde quel est votre est ce qu'il
ya des questions qui serait extrêmement
importante a posé en particulier
peut-être à nos deux invités qui
viennent de témoigner
oui madame il ya un micro là
françois spiero conseillère municipale
déléguée au jumelage à la ville
d'asnières sur seine
mais de temps en temps l'occasion d'être
confronté à des femmes qui sont victimes
de violences et aussi des caps vous avez
évoqué je voudrais dire que tout je les
envoie dans un centre spécialisé pour
aux famines tine de violence la très
grosse majorité d'entre elles acceptent
d'aller une fois ils ne veulent jamais
retourné une seconde fois et la raison
essentielle c'est parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à répondre immédiatement à un
certain nombre de problèmes et c'est je
crois que c'est la gravité la plus
énorme puisque elle manifeste mais
volonté de s'en sortir et elle se trouve
vous confronter un peu à un mur la
l'insuffisance des moyens de ces
structures est énorme et ce qui fait que
elle s'expose quelque part parce
qu'elles prennent des risques en allant
dans ces centres et finalement il n'y a
pas vraiment de réponse alors il ya des
réponses peut-être pour les cas les plus
dramatiques puisque ces centres sont
obligés de faire des choix n'est en
réalité je crois qu'on a un besoin
urgent de palier encore plus à toutes
ces questions là et je voudrais aussi
tout spécialement remercier ces deux
personnes qui ont témoigné de leur vécu
parce que vous pouvoir dépasser un
certain nombre de choses pour faire ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui
merci merci beaucoup nous en sommes
persuadés qu'il manque des des façons
des manières des prises en charge ses
évidentes donc je pense que sur ce point
là une autre question
bonjour alors je me présente je suis
leïla je suis auteur de mariée de force
1 qui est paru il ya quelques années en
france où je dénonce et justement mon
histoire
donc moi j'ai vécu par contre le mariage
forcé donc voilà donc moi la question
que je me pose c'est ne faudrait-il pas
penser peut-être faire de la prévention
vraiment dès le plus jeune âge dans les
collèges et que les politiques français
nous considèrent comme comme des
français à part entière
alors j'ai utilisé en interne qui est
très hard parce que moi ça fait un
certain nombre d'années que j'écris aux
différents présidents la république aux
politiques etc
je n'ai jamais eu aucune réponse si ce
n'est d'être reçus par les conseillers
des uns et des autres mais on m'a
répondu que c'était le problème fac
c'est un problème qui était très très
sensible et qu'il faudrait pas qu'on
soit taxée de d'intrusion dans dans la
vie de ces gens là
enfin ces gens là c'est à dire nous faut
donc voilà alors aujourd'hui au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je me pose
question
je me dis est ce que et là je m'adresse
aux politiques français puisque je suis
franc francs française aussi c'est
sommes-nous à leurs yeux français à part
entière et est ce que ils prennent ils
vont enfin skis il va y avoir au moins
en tout cas au moins une personne je
rêve de voir au moins un politique se
levait et parler de cette problématique
haut et fort en disant voilà nous avons
un problème qui est social social et qui
est français pour nous pour nous venir
en aide et arrêter de se voiler la face
ou doit-on se considérer je m'excuse
vraiment pour les femmes que je vais
utiliser mais c'est vraiment pour faire
violence justement où sommes-nous
considérés comme des bâtards dont la
france ne veulent pas ne veut pas voilà
je suis très dur dans en utilisant ce
propos là mais c'est vraiment pour faire
violence quoi parce qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui moi je suis française
il ya pas mal de problématiques je ne
fais qu'écrire pareil je suis un petit
peu comme karima moi je suis beaucoup
j'en vois beaucoup de courrier un peu à
gauche à droite 1 je pense que la la
poste en tout cas chez qui j'ai enfin ce
qui est juste mais train de me connais
je n'ai jamais eu aucune réponse la
seule réponse que j'ai eu c'est oui mais
vous savez c'est un problème sensible
qu'on a du mal à traiter
donc moi au jour d'aujourd'hui voilà
c'est plusieurs questions je me pose et
je suis intervenu dans pas mal de deux
colloques
je suis allé ensuite j'ai travaillé sur
un documentaire
la suisse se sent beaucoup plus concerné
mal fin heureusement pour vous pour eux
et malheureusement pour nous ce sont
vraiment concernés par la problématique
des mariages forcés et je me rends
compte que nous sommes en 2010 et que et
que voilà les lélés le mariage forcé est
toujours d'actualité
voilà mais vous êtes là aujourd'hui avec
nous et nous nous considérons justement
que c'est un problème et votre ce
colloque aujourd'hui au sénat c'est bien
pour montrer que il faut le prendre en
charge
il faut le regarder en face que les uns
et les autres disent
mais c'est la vraie lutte en mariliza en
parlera cet après-midi j'en suis
persuadé entre des pays qui voudraient
garder des traditions qui les emporte
là où ils sont en espérant que pour
certains que les endroits où ils seront
laisseront faire moi j'ai eu cette
question est certaine dans la salle
peut-être ont connu ces problèmes il ya
20 ans lorsque j'étais secrétaire d'état
aux droits des femmes
j'ai vu un moment s'installer une forme
de d'acceptation de coutume de tradition
de barbarie un moment où
en même en france s'est posé la question
de l'excision
moi à l'époque ministre j'ai dis très
fermement non il est hors de question de
pratiquer l'excision sur le sol français
c'est impossible rien ne le permet je
pense que sur la question de ce n'est
pas la religion qu'ils demandaient quand
bien même elle ne demanderait non non
non donc vous avez devant vous aussi des
politiques qui ne veulent pas de cela
c'est vous considérez citoyens à part
entière et les femmes qui ont tant lutté
pour être citoyenne à part entière
c'était le slogan de mes années de
militantisme de jeunesse nous étions
demandeuses de citoyennes à part entière
pas de sous citoyens comme vous le
demandez aujourd'hui mais il faut le
regarder en face et dire que non la
liberté du mariage s'applique à tous et
nous nous battons d'ailleurs pour
qu'elle s'applique parfois entre des
personnes de nationalités différentes
pour que le droit du mariage soit
appliquée donc ici vous avez une réponse
ferme louis vous êtes nous sommes des
citoyens égaux des citoyennes égal et
nous ne voulons pas de pratiques qui ne
soient pas des pratiques dans lequel on
bafoue la liberté c'est évident je pense
qu'anne marie le redira cet après midi
et nous l'avons montré dans d'autres
espaces ensemble c'est absolument
indispensable de considérer cela comme
ça et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons voulu aujourd'hui posée cette
problématique en tribune
officiellement pour dire nous femmes
parlementaires hommes parlementaire nous
ne voulons pas de pratiques qui soient
des pratiques dans lequel on laisserait
le pas à des traditions mais nous savons
bien que le niveau international est
très difficile nous l'avons vécu il ya
très peu de temps dans une organisation
mû par rapport à un vote dans lequel ces
légendes la tradition qui ont gagné sur
ceux de la liberté c'est ça le combat
donc
nous sommes fermement décidés à ne pas
laisser installer des pratiques qui sont
contraires au libre mariage au libre
choix du mariage même si on considère
que tous ne réussissent pas mais au
moins il y va de son aventure et de sa
vie personnelle
c'est un choix de personnes je veux je
vous aviez demandé aussi j'avais une
main devant et puis après je vous laisse
nos médias micro la nôtre pro garder le
micro c'est mon tour aller oui bonjour
je suis justin reçu au lieu de deux dans
les prés de l'association gamme sa
session qui travaille aussi sur des
thématiques des mariages forcés et
notamment dans l'accompagnement des
victimes
nous faisons partie du réseau agir avec
elle qui qui inclut plusieurs autres
associations dont l'association voix de
femmes dirigées par quels signaux nam
centre et à l'heure par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être peu d'être soulevée comme
comme un oui en formant une lettre très
très près limite le manger quoi bon tous
les bancs d'une micro dont je voulais
préciser par rapport à certaines
thématiques qui a besoin de ressortir
c'est à dire quels accompagnements qu'à
l'accompagnement propose qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire et surtout qu'elle est
finalement le positionnement morale et
politique de la société française je
pense que on est un peu dans une
récurrence c'est à dire que sur
l'ensemble des violences faites aux
femmes en particulier on peut remarquer
qu'il a fallu généralement plusieurs
années voire même décennie 20ème siècle
des fois pour que les choses soient
soient prises en compte et soit mise en
lumière est considérée non plus comme
quelque chose de privé mais comme
quelque chose de sociétal qui intéresse
tout le monde
je pense que sur la thématique des
mariages forcés on est exactement dans
les même schéma avec un sortie si je
pouvais jouer comme ça de handicap
supplémentaire qui est celui de la
culture différente ça que non seulement
ces violences familiales privées etc
mais en plus entre guy massé pâtit chez
nous quoi donc double ou triple tabou ce
qui explique que pendant très longtemps
et encore parfois aujourd'hui on peut se
voir répondre par les services sociaux
la police la loi que bah c'est leur truc
à eux que chez eux ils font comme ça
chez nous ils font comme ça et que donc
on n'a pas s'en mêler au niveau de
l'hébergement
c'est vous avez raison et là c'est
vraiment je crois une et ça a été aussi
mais aussi par vous c'est vraiment
vraiment le socle sur lesquels
aujourd'hui on doit on doit faire
reposer l'accompagnement et la
résolution de ce type de situation là la
france malheureusement est effectivement
pas très en avance sur 7 sur cette
dimension c'est vrai que dans
l'exploration que nous on a pu faire
avec le réseau dans d'autres pays
européens on a remarqué et on a constaté
que certains pays avaient depuis de
nombreuses années mise en place des
dispositifs d'hébergement spécialisés
qui fonctionne bien qui sont vraiment
efficaces compétents et qui font la
démonstration que finalement on peut
régler sur situation là donc on serait
inspiré et c'est aussi l'occasion de
l'annoncé finalement le réseau agir avec
elle a enfin des pistes plus que
sérieuses autour de la création d'un
foyer d'hébergement spécialisés dans
l'accueil des jeunes filles et des
jeunes femmes en situation de rupture
familiale du fait d'une situation de
mariage forcé ou de crimes dits
d'honneur ce foyer s'ouvrira en fait
dans le cadre d'un partenariat avec la
croix rouge
voilà qui sont quelle association
porteuse qui nous permet de qui nous
permet de pouvoir créer cette structure
aujourd'hui on est bien lancé les choses
ont bien avancé mais néanmoins on
continue à avoir besoin du soutien des
politiques à tous les niveaux
parce qu'un foyer vous savez aussi bien
que moi c'est quand même mieux que moi
ça ne s'ouvre pas comme ça ça demande
énormément de des marges soutient pas
ces désagréments valises et dévoila bon
et donc on avance étape par étape mais
on sera sans doute amené encore une fois
vous solliciter prochainement
tout ça pour vous dire que mais les
choses avancent petit à petit et que
je dirais pas qu'il faut être patient
parce qu'on peut pas être patiente
ça c'est clair mais en tout cas voilà on
fur et à mesure les choses continuent de
continuer d'avancer
et puis c'est à nous aussi de continuer
à être peut-être droite dans nos bottes
en disant que bah voilà effectivement
formule on n'a pas voilà c'est pas une
belle formule moi j'aime bien la formule
droite dans ses bottes à j'aime beaucoup
mon nom elle est simple elle est très
minime oui mais oui mais elle est à un
moment donné on parle de choses qui sont
vraies on parle de violence et il n'y a
aucune raison d'être dans la rue avec
une raison d'être dans la dans la nuance
donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que
plus on continue à être droits dans nos
bottes donc l'ecti mention des violences
qui sont inacceptables peu importe
qu'elle soit considérée comme
culturelles et même parfois exotiques
finalement c'est des mots qui peuvent
être employés et que ben on doit
retrouver une résolution efficace voilà
donc ça devance la deuxième table ronde
là qu'on va installer dans quelques
minutes
non je ne vais pas prendre toutes les
questions on aura plusieurs moments des
changes si vous voulez bien
sauf si ça s'adresse vraiment à karima
et à fatou bon je crois que je voulais
c'est à la salsa sur sa valeur globale
permet d'être en fin de matinée voilà
donc je vais remercier christelle hamel
j'ai remercié manuel piette je remercie
facto je remercie karima vous venez de
suivre une première table ronde
organisée à l'occasion de la journée
internationale de la femme sur les
mariages forcés
cet après midi à partir de 16h 30 vous
pourrez suivre la suite de ce colloque
merci de votre fidélité très belle
journée à tous sur public sénat